bag it up this song is perfect for this
segment on the heels of new york fashion
week we're catching up with the designer
behind the it bag that was not on the
runways this season the telford shopping
bag sells out in seconds it's nicknamed
the bushwick birkin for its popularity
in brooklyn's bushwick neighborhood and
a play on the iconic hermes birken bag
that sells out for thousands of
thousands of dollars telfar's vegan faux
leather tote retails for a fraction of
that amount telford clemens designed the
elusive bag but it'll tell you his brand
is so much more we went for a bike ride
with him and then met up at his
headquarters
in brooklyn
i think for so many people they first
heard about you with the bag
that bag yes
tell us about that bag
that bag the telfar shopping bag small
medium large
in a variety of colors it's like
basically the entry point to the brand
telfar clemens brand simply called
telfar has been around since 2005. but
last year sales of his signature bag
skyrocketed it's been spotted on the
arms of celebrities like vanessa hudgins
gabrielle union little nosex and queen
bee herself beyonce
hello hello
and in 2020 his bag made oprah's
favorite things list but even as demand
for telfar's shopping bag rises clemens
says prices which range from 150 to 257
dollars won't change what's your
thinking how far behind uh the price
point
the price point it came from me as like
kind of like a nightlife person that i
would earn my money through dj gig so i
wanted it to be like the price that you
would get
djing one dj gig which was like at the
time like i'm like 150 bucks
200 bucks yeah that makes sense this
thing of hierarchy or exclusivity or you
can't get to me it's like funnier when
it's like you get to me clement's
earliest designs were not those handbags
they were the unisex clothes he says he
wanted to wear
he created his first collection when he
was 18 years old i'd go through the
men's section and then i'd go to the
women's section and then i'll go to the
kids section and it is like you know
just like kind of like that really built
your style now at 36 he's designed the
2020 olympics uniforms for team liberia
his family is from that west african
country and he spent some of his younger
years there
i've heard you say that you want your
line your designs to be genderless yeah
yeah it's genderless you know each thing
is like you know people say that and
they're saying that as like a buzzword
it's not just like something that you
scroll online or see on vogue.com or see
you on the model it's like actually like
no you saw your mom in it and then you
saw your brother at it and you saw it
that's okay
you saw your mom in it and you saw your
brother in it and that's okay
it is okay i don't know why people
pressure themselves so much to be so
stressed
like fashion doesn't have to be
stressful uh-huh you know it can just be
cool
this is yours it's not storyboard what
do you call in the fashion industry
stuff that's coming up
this isn't stuff that's coming up board
yeah so my eye goes to this help me
understand what i hold
what do you call this the thigh hole
jeans
and this is a hot selling item this is
the fastest selling item
we went with clemens and telfar's
creative director babak radboy to their
brooklyn warehouse office and stockroom
there we got a sneak peek at what's
coming up next
now listen i think this is going to give
the bag a run for them this is your
duffel this is new the new bag
one of the first three sizes yes
iterations of the new bag since the
shopping bag i'm so excited about the
duffel
and so this is our actual collection of
like you know all of our classic winter
jacket styles that i've been wanting to
make for so long peacoat and a puff
that's cute that's very sweatpant and a
puff
but why am i so worried about those
thigh out pants you've got to try it out
you're you're overthinking it we're
going to do the five-hole challenge and
i'll show you okay to show you how it's
done
did you find a size for me we found this
outfit i will do it
let's see why this is the highest
selling jean
in the collection
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i know i look ridiculous i just did this
story i will never wear these jeans oh
my god
she's thinking about all of you i salute
you
when you see her and this is wow this is
silly for me
so maybe we should put on the full jeans
and then we could go for a bike ride i'm
down i'm down
does my hat go with my outfit you look
serious
exclusive
you said this isn't even out yet it's
not out
clemens says he bikes from borough to
borough every day getting inspired while
people watching along the way
i see what people are wearing and i'm
like oh oh everybody's wearing this kind
of color and everybody's wearing this
kind of thing it's like each collection
each collection is kind of like a
consensus of what i see or miss see or
what i want to see what do you see or
miss see yeah because like i thought
that person's shirt was going like this
and it's like oh no it's not i should
make that shirt you know what i mean
it seems like whenever you're doing are
you always thinking fashion kind of it's
just like all of this stuff is like
it comes into play and it also helps me
just sort out things that i'm actually
into you know
and now he's thinking forward
instead of a runway show during new
york's fashion week clemens announced
plans for telfar tv a 24 7 public access
channel where people will be able to
purchase new products watch videos
created by consumers and in-house
it's live and it's right now now how
people did learn about the brand is
through social media and social media
has a lot of like regulations you know
and rules that do you like rules i don't
like a rule i don't like a rule when i
when there's a too many rules i move on
to a thing that has no rules that's mine
you know when we appear on other
people's platforms it's just really not
necessarily getting the message across
or it will you know it's just going to
be a lot easier for us to be ourselves
and do what we do you know
it's kind of hard to describe what even
a telfar customer is isn't it it's
everybody yeah yeah as it says not for
you for
everyone everybody yeah
you know he i have to say he is so much
fun after the shoot i sent pictures to
my favorite daughter and favorite son
they said you're not doing that on tv
are you my son goes that's a lot a lot
of thigh and kirby goes my only question
is why why i wanted to show that i will
never wear them but i i see the appeal
for a lot of people yeah but definitely
definitely not for me but i like him he
said when he was growing up he wanted to
be an accountant because he's really
good with numbers but this he says guys
the duffel the duffel the duffel tote is
going to be the new hot bag you know why
he's got a thing called bag security
that if you order it the prices never go
up he will give the key that you will
get it i love it guaranteed i like that
i also like that you can slip a little
dog in here yes
you can it works you can
i can appreciate the humble beginnings
though you know and let that be a
message to anybody that is falling in
love with the craft that might not see
the immediate results he's had his
business since 2005. yeah and he just
popped over the last few years right i
brought this for your favorite daughter
mia okay oh i appreciate that that's i
bought those for
we didn't even have time to take the
paper off i was going to say uh
i'm going to keep this one no no no wait
wait wait wait wait people have to
understand
sometimes stuff it comes in small medium
and large and i think i might keep the
medium well why i get to happy
this is for mia okay all right that's
for your favorite daughter mia you're
watching cbs katie people are not sorry
you're watching cbs we'll be right back
we'll be right back